[Musique]
la situation se complique
les shadoks sont malades et dépérissent
l'egypte y ont des problèmes avec un
autre jbe qui est malade dans la tête
depuis qu'il a perdu son chapeau
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour le calmer on le mettait bien
regarder les shadoks à la télévision
mais tout le monde sait qu'il est très
dangereux de regarder la télévision sans
chapeau et à force voilà il se prenait
pour un shadok voilà qu'ils s'étaient
déguisés au château voilà tu fais chier
camara que tout ça c'était de la
mauvaise graine et compagnie qui gisait
et voilà qu'il voulait retourner voir
son père sa mère et tous ses petits
cousins la bras sur la planète chats
dont il avait pris les commandes du coup
on tresse en allant sur les systèmes
solaires et passait le mur de la lumière
il faisait dérailler les trains et
antimatière et et failles et les
troupeaux de nébuleuse qui s'enfuyaient
d'embellie mais là bas sur la planète
shadoks la terrible maladie
les attendait qu'allait-il se passer
[Musique]